Tammi and Stacy are with us in Tulsa
Oklahoma on our millionaire theme our
hey guys how are you
we're doing great great Dave how are you
better than I deserve so what's your
all's net worth
we are 3.5 3.5 million and what is the
mix of that what's that invested in its
1 million is real estate 250 is IRAs and
the rest is investments bonds mutual
funds to mix okay very cool a little bit
of everything there how old are you guys
I am 50 and I'm 51 all right very good
young millionaires considering his net
worth how much of this did you inherit
nothing zero and what's been your range
of and average household income roughly
through your working life anywhere
between 15,000 to 250 a piece to 250
okay and what careers were you guys in
well our last venture was a portable
restroom company so that's kind of where
it all ended up in the kind of sales and
marketing and on a portable restroom
company okay like porta potties porta
buddy
I love at the porta potti millionaires I
love it it's awesome okay and what were
your degrees in we didn't I had a court
reporting certificate but neither one of
us had a college degree Wow agree of
hard knocks here yeah okay so have you
owned businesses or what did you do to
other than the porta-potties is the last
venture but what have you done to earn
your living what's been your general
career track I work for a fortune 500
waste management company
this is though basically in the I went
to my friends always tell me went from
scrap to crap days and that's where I
did that
that's a great line
and it worked out for you I'll just tell
you
haha very good did so what was your GPA
in high school since you didn't go to
college uh Dave how about my teachers
called my wife and said you need to get
him to class okay the last one so I
didn't do too well in school God shine
mine was a three point eight okay so
that's why you were getting him to class
I got it okay all right he married the
smart girl good for him all right uh it
worked out good this is fun so how much
of the three and a half million would
you say is the result of you borrowing
money in order to build wealth and we
started off borrowing 100,000 to start
the business and then we did not borrow
money again until we had to start till
we bought our partner out which that was
1.2 million to buy him out okay and are
you debt-free now yes she turnaround
paid that back off then oh yes as soon
as yes okay what part has giving played
in your fraud in your financial planning
well you know that's a lot of things
when when I was growing up that the
money I earned I actually that was one
of my fault I would give it away so
that's kind of you know we've we've
learned a lot from exactly what you had
mentioned you know we save and give we
don't know give financially but we give
a lot of ourselves just to help people
we have a ministry and so we do a lot of
ministry work and help people as much as
we can and we believe whatever God leads
us to do that's kind of kind of where
we're at
gotcha it's the most expensive pair of
jeans you ever bought mine is 50 Dave I
still have some the jeans from high
school so I'm not sure I keep telling
bad you need to get some new jeans but I
my last thing I bought was running shoes
gotcha okay and what's the best vacation
you guys have ever taken well Dave the
best vacation is probably we been to
Dominican Republic but we're getting
ready to celebrate our 30 year
anniversary so that's going to be a one
trip in a lifetime
bora-bora Oh ding-ding yes you should
you better that's awesome that's how you
do it that's how you do it so what
advice have you got to the 23 year old
you that's listening and this still be
done in America yes it most certainly
can I think the best advice I would say
is we work together since we've been
together and communication having goals
together and know where you're going
with a business and also financially
always having a budget work hard while
you can with a balanced life but at the
same time say no matter what I don't
care if it's ten cents or a dollar each
paycheck you always have to be saving
how many books a year do you to read
well day but I actually reload I think
that's one of the things that really got
me along in life and I'd mention that to
any young entrepreneur male or female to
read a lot read a lot of leadership
books something that continues building
you up and esteem I mean there's a lot
of great books out there
you know one of them definitely is the
inspired leadership by Dave Ramsey which
is a great one and then you know just a
lot of books and then also inspirational
things we would do is put cards up you
know all things are possible whom to
believe you know a true entrepreneur is
a doer not a dreamer just things that
always remind us that you know we're
better than the world we can definitely
conquer everything just keep on keeping
on but I probably read four or five
books a month Wow okay very cool very
cool that's great advice
you guys are absolute rockstars three
and a half million dollars enjoy Bora
Bora you've earned it I'm proud of you
okay thank you
we just great appreciate you Dave and
all you've done and how you spread the
word you know it is a true thing it's
just one last thing my daughter does
keep the thing in her dashboard of a car
if you live like no one else later you
can live like no one else so she sat in
a car and remind circle eighteen old
friends to do the same that's perfect
and she can point to her mom and dad and
say that's how they did it that's
exactly how they did it
you guys live like no one else and now
you're able to live and give like no one
else and it fits the pattern of your
life it's who you are it's the character
of your personhood
way to go I'm so honored to talk to you
you're heroes that's very very cool hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a five
hundred thousand dollar income